gang the state trashy tour is coming to
a city near you stand up comedy plus
we've played the Leo IG with the crowd
shows are selling out and you can get
your tickets at rugarbage.com see you
there
[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that the girl to be classy
yeah those are just a big old piece of
trash I'm your hostage Foley coming at
you on a beautiful day we're out back
here at hoodies in the new edition yeah
she's out in the garage playing with a
new bug zapper okay okay
stick in the neighborhood kids fingers
in it all right fair enough
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table it's a family episode he is
the CEO of Ru garbage and let me tell
you this gang when he's not stuffing
goldfish down his face that was one
night or yelling at his dog he's the
king of the boardwalk baby Mr Neptune
2023. give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan
what up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate view
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
then obviously the greatest gosh darn
website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage you go
over there you sign up for all your
bonus content you get five dollar
episode you got a 10 level where you get
hard feelings which is that's where the
rubber hits the road over there check it
out gang it's apartheid runaway hit that
hard feelings it's one one sweeps week I
heard and then obviously are you
garbage.com for all the tour date
tickets all the links are up there shows
are selling out left and right we're
adding them we're babbing them bebopping
scatting them don't forget the t-shirts
and Zippo style lighters
legally obligated [__] big lighter
came and shut us down
those guys from Bic don't play around
Jimmy Zippo the third goal
told me to zip it all right how about a
nice quick shout to our prescription
extraordinaire big man's got cured meats
on a break yeah a little corned beef in
me how about a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good works the
ones the twos the threes and the fours
he crosses the t's and he dots the eyes
he is uh he took a run this summer for
Mr Neptune he was out there every
morning down here at the shore [__]
hitting the waves on his skin board give
it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody what up dudes what's
up I cannot believe how badly I missed
the Jersey Shore I spent years talking
[__] about this place it's the greatest
love it love it everybody gave me [__]
uh you got a big head a small pee pee
that's got nothing to do with how good
the Jersey Shore is okay gang it's been
weeks it feels like years I know uh
that's well that's one thing I wanted to
bring up
was Hal we stayed in a nice Gene yeah
very nice joint out there in the water
uh you can sign up to patreon check out
all them vids which usually a lunch it
with the airbnbs ah don't give me that
if anybody's ever launched it on an
Airbnb a Jew you've gotten us thrown out
that that's a lunch in it again but I
didn't I didn't pick the place you got
us thrown out of it we've been in more
haunted houses than not would you agree
with that what yeah that's well this is
hard feelings that's [__] crazy
that's nuts I'm always here in the
hallway the religious house religious
house what do you mean it was just House
of God where was the religious house I
don't know there was that one place with
the room that was only dolls yeah
remember the doll room I thought you
guys would like that place
whoa we're trying to have fun you did
good I did I did well yeah the boy did
well but it showed me how much we
don't deserve nice things sure we were
just very out of place in that house
sure with the neighbors with that we you
know they were counting our days for us
to get out of there oh my God it was and
then like even cleaning up we weren't
about breaking we didn't know
do we do this do we do that do we leave
money on the dresser what do we do we
didn't know we forgot that I don't know
if we were supposed to leave money but
we did not yeah leave them all leave
money yeah no for what for all those
[__] beer cans with heater butts in
them
oh dude that was a Minefield man if I
got I was like I was like hanging out at
Putin's house you don't know whether
you're gonna get poisoned or not oh man
I had a couple you would all you always
have to do the shake test and then give
it a sniff test surprise I didn't get I
caught a couple of them in college man
God damn it that'll ruin a mixer
trying to look cool
he's trying to look cool in front of the
d5e girls
yikes yeah uh but it was just very funny
of all of us together normally anytime
I've ever been in a place that nice it's
been with a representative family family
a friend who's like I know we don't know
how to operate in a place that nice now
we were like going through the rule book
and stuff making
doing crab dumps in the bay yeah that's
yeah uh what the [__]
cut that
God damn EPA will be all over us it was
mostly corn on the cob and potatoes
something for the crabs to get in there
Jesus Christ T-Bone there was an oil
slick I'm kidding it was all water it
was a water-based boil
it was just very like we didn't want to
try to get Old Bay off the Coast Guard
Cutter
we were leaving lights on screen doors
open it was bad oh yeah that was we were
trapped we was AC on windows down that
was we were [__] real trash in there
kitchen full of flying bugs oh yeah it
was bad dude at one point I was thinking
about hanging up fly paper just to get
them they were everywhere catch me in it
the next morning oh wait on my eyebrows
yeah yeah it was a good time baby uh I
got one I got one two three things I
want to jump into uh obviously
supermarkets are a very big deal sure in
our in our program in our lives sure
we've been removed from the Suburban uh
supermarkets for a long time being
living in New York for so long which are
the it's the creme de La Creme yeah and
I go to the like when I when I go visit
my mom whatever I go to the one that I
went to growing up it's kind of the same
you know facelifts and stuff like that
but it's the same I went to I don't know
if this was
I went to a Wegmans
that place
is still wetting there nuts yeah they
got someone slicing proscute for you
really like they sliced cheese like she
was back there [__] carving it put
like freshly sliced
my wife my wife had never been she's
like this real Italian bro too bring her
over from Italy like furio and The
Sopranos uh it was why it was like like
to the point where I go I'm not
comfortable here didn't feel comfortable
they didn't have all the brands I liked
the apples are too shiny it was trusted
yeah it was everything was too good I go
give me a [__] give me an Acme give
me a shop right a Super Fresh shopping
bag something every day kind of guy yeah
this is hoity toity this was out of my
realm I like that wet bathing suit like
a damp bathing suit
couple Eddies in you later in the
evening maybe like five six o'clock you
gotta run down to a nice grocery store
that air conditioning hit you when you
walk in there man that's clean living
yeah that play it's they're trying
too cool that they're not trying but
they're trying [__] on Wegmans I got one
item that'll turn your tune right around
they do an in-house chili con queso dip
that will knock your compressions
it's not hot it's it's like canned it no
I like Jarred it's containered
it's in like a little Tupperware type
deal dude trust me I ate about four
pounds of prosciutto I mean I'm not
saying I'm not saying I I'm not saying I
didn't indulge while I was there but
it's just not a [__] run it's Kevin
Ryan I'm a rich industrialist I'd like
to try your Vegito I'm a prosuto man to
see if I'm going to invest in your
Wegmans
your weakness
ah yes it's like a new Nike sneaker
95 Wegmans
yeah I don't know it was just very UNS
it was also very crowded and I get that
it's very it is very nice very nice high
end just didn't give me the didn't give
me the vibe I needed you're more of a
you like dude you're shopping at a gas
station
that BP I used to live next to had a
good selection and you know it if you
don't have peanuts in a 99 cent sleeve
Kippy starts getting nervous yeah I want
the cheap ones too not planners what are
you having a combination cheddar and
beef stick
yeah nothing I was those things suck by
the way I've never had a good one of
those like there's just the two tubes
like the two yeah never had a good one
I've ever had always wanted them when I
was a kid I could maybe squeeze a slim
jim out of Patty but never those that
was like asking for duck if I could
wanna one of those
hey you want you you want your cheese
and beef sticks go down to wedgmans will
you
I saw a guy the other day at the grocery
store do the move I was stunned by this
I can't believe the guy didn't freak the
[__] out
the guy goes up to the counter he says
let me get a pound of turkey paper thin
which I respect that's the gentleman's
move that I mean that should just be
what psychopath is going into a grocery
store say give it to me sick
I don't know it's not for me but I'm
sure people do it otherwise that would
be the standard that it's that should be
the standard it should be paper thin
unless you're trying to get away with
serving that for dinner like like like
you know like that is turkey but you eat
the stuff out of the Tupperware that's I
don't like that that's that's paper thin
that's Hillshire Toby likes it too
that's the Red Top no full of nights
let's go that shit's track did I have a
couple sammies with it oh man it's too
slimy I got a heavy hand with that too
no and I put that on my on my on my net
zero carb tortilla oh that's a lump of
meat let me get an extra thin extra
sweaty it's like it's been sitting out
enough christening for too long and they
bagged it up a treadmill at equinox
you open it up it's like a [__]
goddamn rainforest in there who put the
turkey in the sauna what's going on yeah
you're saying we're just trying to cut
waves man sweating like a fat girl
playing dodgeball but this guy goes let
me get it let me get a paper thin the
kid behind the counter slices one up and
he goes how's this the guy goes that's
great then he puts that back in that's
an offeratory slice if you're showing
the slice you got to give it to the you
got to give it to the customer I do you
are not wrong well I tend to well I tend
to believe you're wrong in a lot of
things sir you are not wrong on that my
only thing I even reached for it a
little bit [__] out of here my only
thing is there is there may be some sort
of covet protocol that it's left though
I don't know
I'm asking I don't [__] know free
lunch meat never hurt anybody I'm just
saying hand to hand maybe no he's got
the kid and a glove on I understand it's
fingerless but still those big J was
back uh I understand what you're saying
but I'm saying maybe they were like they
just did it away with it at some point I
don't know I haven't ordered no I had it
a couple I had it a couple weeks ago
they gave me a slice
yeah I was just a calm you down
easy easy we'll get you we'll get you
your cheese easy there's the car guy
petting you easy I was holding the guy's
kid huh
one of them big pickles too I like
tossing fish to a seal yeah
keep them in front of you at all times
uh no obvious yes that should of course
that's the thing but I'm just saying
maybe I don't know maybe there's a our
times are tough I don't [__] know
they should be giving out every kid
should get a slice of cheese too by the
way or nice slices of cheese I forgot a
seven-year-old bold man I forgot about
that they would give me a slice of
cheese to shop me if you think I wasn't
if you think likes of American man that
brings back memories dude me and my
brother he'd have it on like a little
wax paper and he hand it to us it was
like communion yeah it was great I don't
think we ever had to laugh I think I was
just getting [__] like you were
hitting a dime bag in Baltimore just
[__] they were just trying to get it
to stick to your forehead no but I would
get a [__] well my great love affair
of bread of roll of cheese and rolls was
from when I was a kid it's Super Fresh I
would already have a roll because that
was right there no you wouldn't yeah
you'd make a sandwich I wouldn't make a
sandwich I would do a bite for bite type
deal
oh are you sitting in the cart with your
little legs kicking yeah yeah I was
young swollen ankles
come on take me to goldfish aisle oh man
as you caught it the aquarium
they can't tell me [__] I would get a
roll right as right as we got in they
had to give they had to give me just a
plain roll to keep me from [__]
fidgeting Jesus nothing's better than a
fresh roll out of that out of that
[__] container with the tongues we
didn't use tongs either I ain't put it
back I had a hand-to-hand combat Daddy
yeah it's all right yeah a little slice
of cheese American cheese though trashy
it's pretty all right sure that Cooper's
sharp ain't too bad which might be a
local thing
Tommy Pope turned this on to that my dad
used to [__] with it he was the only guy
I ever knew that that had it all he
talked Cooper sharp get Cooper sharp
Tommy's the only other guy I ever met
that that knows that knows about it but
I think it's a local Philly thing can
you give that a GOOG
it's Cooper sharp National or
International for all I know could be
doing shows in Italy I'm sure it's
relative I'm sure it's relatively bigger
I don't think there's like local cheeses
like that sure there is in this day and
age yeah it's an international economy
you don't think they like [__] Cooper
sharp cheese out there in Minnesota well
I'll tell you what it's down here in
Philly it is is it oh yeah it's a Philly
thing 1893 same Grace same Great Taste
from 1893 to today Cooper shark is that
the brand is it a company
uh yes really Cooper brand Cooper brand
oh I just thought it was like a version
of shark so did I Cooper sharp cheese is
it it's an american cheese they have a
whole variety they do oh yeah I didn't
know that oh yeah I know that label let
me say it it's like government cheese
that stuff
oh my God that's it that's not good that
looks like a Coors Banquet beer dude
that's something to eat when the brains
around yikes yeah okay
but shout out to Cooper sharp shout out
to it
um I always thought it was like a just
like a sharp cheddar of some sort yeah I
thought it was some kind of weird
American
I hear some kind of weird American
patriotic
goddamn Patriot respect me will you eat
my Cooper sharp
uh but gang it's a goddamn Family
episode uh so let's get down to the
business as you know when you sign up
for patreon we will answer your garbage
question on here the homies get the
first [__] crack at it and with that
being said let's jump into it this one's
from Sean ten dollar homie never had one
red spelled red wrong is it garbage is
it garbage just suddenly realizes one
day that you're at your you're 10 years
into a summer job
whole that hits you at lunchtime hard
yeah the steam coming off that t-shirt
press what's going on here I wonder if
he's down ashore if he's no it's
probably like Lane my thought was like
Landscaping construction sure something
that like you're rolled into [__] I
did that when they kicked me out of
school I rolled that summer job right
into the fall sure I need to clean up
the leaves who's gonna plow the snow you
know what I mean exactly no yeah I don't
think any I did I actually most of my
summer jobs
I feel could have led there was no
seasonal work I didn't really that
wasn't a seasonal guy I would always
I've talked about on the patreon I
always get these weird [__] these
weird jobs of just like working at a
Safe Company [__] digging ditches
just all this weird [__] when I worked
under the bridge of 95 with the bridge
people that was another yeah
you're jammed up when your boss has a
job that's [__] the owner of the
company had a job I was like this this
ain't right
he's a doorman somewhere I gotta go
drive I gotta go make drop off I'm still
making you sign this yay
yeah yeah 10 years is a while it's one
of those things though if you get it in
your 20 you know 21 22 that my 20s leap
year it was like a black hole of time
for my 20 like 22 to 32
that was a white hole
you're 35 with a pool whistle in your
mouth
that's a sweet gig though man those guys
are all in shape they get to wear those
cool shorts plus they get to save people
and [__] plus the broads probably ain't
that bad
it's got to be a cut off on that though
yeah you can't be a [__] 45 year old
I mean Hasselhoff was the leader though
he was like 35 when that happened you
think yeah dude I was young Baywatch she
was 50 in my head he had a kid a [__]
teenage boy that he knocked up some
broad when he was young they it's in the
storyline he was like 16 17. you're so
you're so ingratiated in the storyline I
was there for the jugs you know what I
mean [__] I didn't need a plot I like
their gear they had sweet gear those
those La uh lifeguards they had so much
better show the [__] the Jersey Shore
they got a canoe or something like that
they're out there on a pedal boat
and a duck
I thought Hasselhoff had a piece in that
no you sure yes I thought he had a
shotgun
[Laughter]
somebody tell those sharks I mean
business
I could have swore he had some nickel on
him no the Coppell anytime something
came the cop always came to save the day
and the cop had the the dark ATV yeah he
rolled up in the Blues he was all right
shout out to that guy tight little body
of that kid probably closing closing
but I always hate him when I found out
that they shot those scenes in a pool
the underwater scenes in a that was my
first glance into Hollywood more like
Holly what did you [__] think they
were doing I don't know Sam Anderson out
in the [__] off Catalina Island I
mean it's shark country you know what
first of all you were [__] 22 when it
was on so cut me some slack I can see
right through that [__] ah
yeah no I they were like so my brother
told me or something and I was like no
way and then you watch him it's a kid
diving for rings in the back of the shot
it's a ducking for quarters see the lane
lines behind them come on what are we
doing don't swim let's go
yeah I did love their Huts though oh
yeah they had like you could live in
there that was like a two bedroom that's
what I'm talking about it's all right
get the AC up there if I can peering out
big pair of binoculars that was all
right so I don't know what this kid's
doing but hey man if it's working for
you it's working hey if it's 10 years
it's 10 years baby keep paying summer
gig nothing wrong with it yeah keep the
lights on okay let's talk about mid
mobile oh shout out to that man hey you
like that Ryan Reynolds sharp kid you
know movie star like that when he had
the company before he sold it he could
probably charge 80 90 100 for a plan
what'd he charge 15. 15 bucks and I tell
you what they're still doing at 15
starting playing it's crazy we're
talking 5G networks we're calling no
brick and mortar we're talking passing
the savings right on to you get on that
mint mobile yeah uh the fact that it's
all digital means there's no stores like
the big man said you're not paying a
rent there the electricity for uh people
to be you know uh smoking doobies in the
break room yeah horsing around playing
grab ass none of that it's fantastic
I've been saying it for you my wife's
been using it for eight years now uh
it's easy peasy you plug it in play it's
the same thing it's everything just way
cheaper all plans come with limited talk
text high speed data on the nation's
largest 5G Network you can even keep 5G
you keep your same number all your
contacts the only thing that changes the
amount of money left in your pocket that
goes up that's all right uh to get your
new Wireless plan for just 15 beans a
month and get the plan shipped right to
your door for free go to mintmobile.com
garbage that's mintmobile.com garbage
call your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com
okay let's talk about factor factor
factor factor big big fans at a factor
meals over here at Ru garbage had one
today even before they we were they were
sponsors I found them about two two
years ago dipping into them baby the
number one ready to eat meal plan in
America uh you sing it sister two
minutes in the microwave we're talking
top shelf dishes right there it's on the
plate ready to go a lot of people say
that if you want to eat well you got to
put a lot of time in the kitchen not
when it comes to factor they do it for
you in and out the door baby do yourself
a favor I tell you right now they do
some kind of mashed cauliflower it's all
right
I'm a big fan I just have one this
morning I'm a big fan of the shredded
chicken taco ball I take that out I dump
it on a pan I heat that up well that's
happening for seconds they give you a
little sauce open that up dump that on a
little mix with a spatchi or a spoon
I'll tell you this boom right my goalie
you want to share save your eyebrows try
that turkey chili whoa oh yeah top shelf
big fan uh so head to factormeels.com
garbage50 and use code garbage 50
garbage 5-0 to get 50 off holy [__]
they're giving it away baby that I might
create a fake account and join again
that's code garbage50 at factormeels.com
garbage50 to get 50 off it's in a show
notes gank do it uh all right this one's
from Victor ever had a Bob Marley poster
no now I did I had his greatest hits for
a long time though
the CD
yeah I had one I was in sixth grade
it was you know
did a poster no I didn't add the CD sure
everybody yeah it was like that age
where you find it and you're like you
find one song you're like you play that
50 times in a row sure no woman don't
cry
tosses your room for Junk
if you have a Bob Marley poster there's
a plastic alien head bong lurking
somewhere somewhere yeah uh I didn't
have that no I didn't have any
real bad like [__] trashy I did like I
had like a bunch of beer stuff in my
teens that was my identity
still kind of is uh
uh yeah that's about it I didn't have
any like I guess I did have a G Unit
post or not I think I Had the Blues
Brothers
by the big Blues Brothers uh one that
that's very of the time for you like the
cool thing at some point yeah I bought
it at uh I had that in a Rolling Stones
a Hot Rocks one that I bought at a
poster convention down in Philly my
buddy closed their convention my buddy
my buddy's dad who was really into like
classic rock drove us down there hot
rock sounds like the worst as seen on TV
product yeah get some hot rocks and your
posters tired of [__] on a cold
toilet seat try Hot Rocks Hot Rocks was
great you went to a poster convention
yeah I think it was a poster convention
I would have chicks there
um yeah I remember his dad got a Grand
Funk Railroad
uh poster I think this guy smokes weed
Oh yeah talk about toss in his room that
was [__] suspect list number one I
remember the first guy with first dad by
the time you work on Monday
I didn't even know you got nasty the
first uh the first Dad we saw I found
smoked weed we were you know sixth
seventh grade or whatever and then he
was driving us to the mall or somewhere
and he's like I just gotta stop by my
garden we were like what he drove us
like
he were able I had like a not a commune
like uh what if there's like shared
guard he worked at a shared Garden where
you had like your own 10 by 10 space and
he was growing Chiba I don't think he
was growing oregano what he went out
there and picked I don't know he had to
do something he didn't let us near it
like we were like he's like stay in the
car and he like wandered over to his
[__] Panama Red holy [__] took the
crop yeah man you've been on a drug run
with somebody's parents and you put it
like that yeah that doesn't sound great
holy [__] oh yeah stuff in the bag in
your underwear that was about that life
from an early age cops won't search it
hey everybody take your [__] will you
holy [__] yeah I never thought of that
yeah
he probably was meeting this guy back
there
no it was growing
don't take the other people in the co-op
they're probably mine are all in on it
what are you talking about
let's put a couple I probably went to a
grow house sprinkle a cup of rotten
tomatoes in the ground yeah damn growing
it
I guess yeah I remember we found he had
like this brick weed it was the first
weed I ever seen in a brick yeah he
wasn't growing that dude he probably had
a duffel buried back there
buy some cucumbers or something
I don't know but yeah brick weed you got
it's got to get compressed I'm sure he
has we uh he's he's grown weed he can't
compress it what are you talking about
no you step on it no no I don't
understand what you're saying but maybe
he was growing his own and that was his
[__] that was his stash he also had
the box of easy whiters
the dispenser like you pull out like
that the store has you open up his like
armoire and it had like the box and he
would just pull out a whole pack of it
oh this guy was heavy into it yeah
goddamn Criminal
Jesus crazy
man stopping by the plugs roll my first
joint on that paper you can always tell
you walk in a room you're like there's
weed and when you're like sick when
you're six or seven you walk into a room
yeah you can smell weed right away 100
because you had smelled it once and it's
the first time you've ever smelled
anything like that it's never a
comforter on the bed it's always a
blanket oh yeah you know something's up
it has drapes but aren't real drapes
yeah real blinds yeah it's kind of got
comforter money this guy's High
something
the money's going somewhere dude uh you
know what video that I saw not too long
it was an oldie when the dude does like
the [__] sativa or what is it the DMT
or whatever not the DMT Salvia and jumps
out the window that thing's making the
rounds again man he climbs that wall
she knocks off to the side he starts
[__] Stairway to Heaven he jumps out
so it's a picture window he jumps out
the top part of the picture holds the
it's a double hung he pulls it down and
goes out the top he doesn't know what's
happened and I gotta be honest that
wasn't the first floor man he comes back
in he comes back in through the front
door too does he I don't know I never I
never caught the sequel oh man that's
all [__] right
um all right let's see here this one's
from Far Town shout out to you uh ten
dollar homie here never have one red
have you or anyone in your family had a
profile pic on social media with
yourself or someone else holding a fish
that's
for sure for sure my stepdad every
profile pic was uh had a fish in it my
uh by Myspace page has a couple of
quote-unquote album covers
that's still floating around T-Bones
already on no floating around
yeah
still good is that still like an active
website I don't think any I don't have
anything on there no it's all gone all
myspaces or his profile his profile it's
gone yeah you got some tracks up though
no I don't
I don't think they'll play the disguise
Koga under an hour senior class trip the
shame all the hits baby I mean that's
[__] that's the double disc right
there gang
I don't think they play
oh they play no they don't
now
this is just a back door album release
plug ah you don't say hit him with the
banner man cut that I gotta want to dig
that stuff out
um the record company shut it down
batty Patty pulled the bloggy odor 500.
I've never paid her back for Studios she
wasn't able to recoup so she pulled the
plug on MySpace
oh that's great this one from craymond
um
have you ever used the phrase I got some
money coming in soon when asking someone
to spot you [__] yeah [__] my whole life
uh-huh I was the king of thinking I was
gonna have a hundred bucks next week
yeah king of it yeah let me borrow 40
now I'll give that and when I get my
Hundred I'll give you your 40 back and
still have six waiting on a residual
check man I remember doing jobs when I
was younger in my 20s and 30s where you
weren't gonna get it for a couple of
weeks yeah processing payroll back in
the day I couldn't remember why Tammy in
this office took forever doing paperwork
when me and my brother did that uh that
that asbestos job at the at the Hatboro
horse I'm putting it in oh thanks
[__] idiot
now we were eating it uh that took like
three weeks well if the problem with
for the younger youngsters out there
your first paycheck at a job in the 80s
nine 2000s they don't still do that no I
think a lot of them are like three weeks
it was well it was they and that's if
you got paid for training yeah so it was
like your first week where that fell in
their pay cycle they always held it for
two weeks or whatever did you get jammed
up and be like and that's when you
needed money the [__] motion your
first week of a new job but after three
weeks that check was nice yeah you gotta
but then you got used to spending like
that
and then the real check roll the the
weekly check or the buy and that really
[__] well you had to make yourself
whole again too because you were big
borrowing and stealing that was those
three weeks
keeping those plates spinning I got a
check coming
have you ever signed a check over to
anybody well every every check I ever
got went right to my mom for the cash
now give me I'm going out give me the 15
bucks from Pop Pop I need a pack of
eaters a [__] Diesel from Wawa let's
go
yeah always he throwing a slice of
cheese for the gifts did you ever do you
ever owe somebody money were you to sign
a check over to them
I'll sign you over a check I'll sign you
I'll I'll make the check to you that's a
move you make while being hung out a
window yeah
you had to do that
for way too late in your life you were
you've been signing checks over since
I've known you sure you were signing
I'll just sign a check over to them yeah
I remember being like that's what the
that's what they did in three Den day
you're nuts that's crazy pay to the real
official pay to the order of so yeah pay
to the yeah you've yeah pay to the order
yeah
um
damn
pay to the order of Slick Rick please
keep moving that's [__] jammed up but
that was my life man I used to be able
to I used to be able to thank god of the
anxieties going of keeping this
placement but keeping those plates
plates been in wisdom I thrived on it
being nervous signing the check so you
didn't [__] it up at all oh yeah oh I
just go below that line better not
[__] keep this also this is what I
want to talk about I just got 20 how old
am I 36 37 by the time this comes out
checks he's got checks checks first time
as a grown adult I have checks what are
you doing with those checks big man
uh to pay for something and I had to
order I couldn't order them I couldn't I
didn't have checks my whole life last
time I had checks
I had starter checks and I and I wrote a
150 check to get a house in the Poconos
with my friends and I bounced it
and I it was 150 for the weekend for
everybody and I was like I'll gather the
money so I gathered the money you piece
of [__] I spent I never deposited the
money I spent the money bounced the
check wow did you do that on purpose or
you did it by accident by accident
uh-huh what do you mean yikes I mean she
I had to give her the 150 plus the 35.
for the bounce check
which I I mean the story I painted her
sure that's an old account my
assistant's an idiot meanwhile
that's the lesson I mean Vinnie you know
something's got to happen here let me
talk to my associate Vinnie with the
skinny man yeah jammed up but I felt
very proud this morning I put my
checkbook together you put the little
transaction thing in there you're gonna
write that [__] down nah so you keep
track of it be like well like my mother
get in fights
on the checkbook
if the aliens ever find that they won't
know what to make of it she's that
things like hieroglyphics oh nine
different languages [__] carrying
threes picture you with a knife through
your head yeah uh no I only have to cut
I have to cut one a month
uh so I'll just do that probably okay
I mean I'm not gonna be writing you
should get one of those books
they're for businesses you should get
one of those for what I don't know I
mean TiVo can grab a couple of them I
come in you're stuffing them down your
shirt trying to get to the Yankees game
one
Gippy said it's cool
I swear I'm writing to check for a half
a lobster you're in a suit no seriously
play cool play cool uh all right this
one's from Keenan is it garbage have a
mixed drink with a Lunchable oh man
gotta get something in the stomach that
is a little bit of charcuterie to an
extent if you're jammed up talk about
slimy have you felt one of those the ham
and cheese ones never they never liked
them that's thick cut right there yeah
that's a good that's like a brick of
baloney yeah they should slice that up a
little bit they should come out with
Lunchables for adults classy Lunchables
clenchables
classical slight that's not bad that's
it that's top of the class
[Music]
now that says nothing about
sure it's for AP students only
uh A Touch of Class touch a class
that's not bad
they should there should be Lunchables
for adults
it's a charcuterie board they have those
Oscar Meyer my oscar if they have that
like Del Forno or whatever one whatever
the [__] it is whatever those guidos are
doing
can't keep up with those [__] Del
forna I think it's a gutter company yeah
we'll do your gutters no they're great
yeah that's what I'm saying that's
that's lunchable for an adult I got the
cracker ones but I meant Lunchables
Oscar Meyer should do it for The
Branding okay get on the phone call up
Oscar write him a check I don't have the
checkbook what are you talking about
um all right let's see this one's from
Blake ten dollar homie here is a garbage
to approach and play a public piano
whether you're good or not hotel lobbies
museums
Etc man you gotta be real good no or
really bad and the pregame show has to
be big yes cracking knuckles uh rolling
the sleeves up and then you hit him with
a block crossbars
you're nuts if you don't think I walk up
there
when I said my cousin showed me that I
thought I was [__] Wolfgang Amadeus
himself uh-huh because I couldn't do the
uh what's it Chopsticks
that's not chopsticks
that's it I couldn't do that for some
reason I could do it a little bit but
that's the heart and soul duet heart and
soul duet yeah found with the Google
search the song two people play on a
piano yeah because it's the one that
every two everybody two people know man
I couldn't do it but I could do that I
could [__] drop my knuckles I did it
not too long ago showing off for my
nieces and nephews and they're like you
can play a piano I said get back relax I
was in sticks
I remember my mom they thought there was
a there was about four days in 1983
where my mother thought that I was a
piano
virtuoso Prodigy and that is 100
dead serious why because I was down at
myself
we were down at my cousins for Easter
and they had a piano and I think just
for half a second I [__] was slamming
on the piano and something made sense
for maybe a second just something and
then we strung together a half a quarter
something and then we have a scale we
went back and my mom was telling
everybody that she thinks I'm a prodigy
and I remember she took us to the
Wyoming Valley Mall and it was they were
out in the mall it wasn't a store there
was a bunch of pianos they used to do
that yeah like just fill space or like
attract people or they would have people
play well back in the day Maul's like
used to be [__] concerts and stuff
like Britney Spears no they were selling
these there was a bunch of different
pianos in a sales no I know I know yeah
yeah but there were there's typically a
hub somewhere to that
and I'm I remember my mom trying to get
a deal on this piano and she was telling
the guy that he that he has real talent
real town and if we could really like
you'd be doing you would be doing a
service to music yes and Society yes if
you give this fat little bastard a steal
on a piano and I remember I played a
little bit ladies getting chocolate all
over the keyboard what are you doing
dude I played a little bit and he just
walked away he's like ah lady the price
is the price
she's got boogers on my Yamaha
I was ahead of my time
he didn't get it you don't understand
it's the notes he's not playing
[Music]
it's like jazz yeah that's uh that's a
tough look
I don't think uh I don't think she ever
any time your family thought that you
were good at something and you really
weren't was a tough luck
I mean that was everything up my whole
life
until I mean my mom's never eaten rolls
my mom just thought I started being good
at this and up until now it was like I
mean this podcast was happening and she
was she goes can you go get another job
she want me to go back to Macy's hey
that's zip it all right do a little
squirting I mean the fat man got
something good here all right
uh yeah I sucked at everything every
dude I was so bad at the guitar so bad I
was I just wanted to shred and we went
to this place called we gotta put the
time in we went to this place we
probably got chasing tail you gotta you
got to put it in I was living the dream
it was living the life it's all sex
drugs and rolls with me
uh uh
until we go to this let's Place House
guitar just sucked and I just wanted to
[__] shred and melt faces and I you
know and they they stifled my creativity
is what they did teaching me like Barney
and [__] [__] like that trying to
[__] rock over here okay what do you
know about Trade coffee Oh you mean the
best in the best nice cup of coffee from
the fellas over there a trade I'm
telling you right now gang your cup of
coffee could be the best part of your
day you don't know what's gonna happen
you know what I mean step into a puddle
you get splashed it only gets worse
after that cup of coffee high school
kids throwing eggs at you you never know
what's gonna happen so do yourself a
favor get some Trade coffee their
algorithm matches what kind of coffee
you like and then they take it from
there baby it's easy peasy yeah trade
connects people to the best coffee
roasters in the country ships fresh
freshly roasted coffee right to your
door they were nice enough they've been
sending it here and I gotta tell you
it's like a goddamn Diner out there
though man big amount of coffee we're
serving up I'm giving it today you want
some try to trade try to trade I'm
hopped up on caffeine plus you know
where it's coming from you don't want to
be drinking blood diamonds you know what
I mean a couple of blood beans you get
trade has free shipping customizable
plans and easy cancellation anytime so
you truly have nothing to lose get ready
for the best coffee give it a shot of
your life with trade go to
drinktrade.com
ayg to receive a free bag of coffee with
any subscription that's a free bag of
coffee with any trade subscription at
drinktrade.com
ayg or by clicking a link in our show
notes your next cup of coffee is on a
boys know it can you think up what
letter comes after another letter in the
ABCs without singing the song
try what like uh if you were not really
but try and you in music or just the
regular alphabet in the regular alphabet
I like this go ahead me l m
e
f
j i that's gay
I know that it's K you have to sing this
song every single time Jesus
I thought I was stupid
don't sell yourself short big guy I
think you are very I am a prodigy
if I knew all of them
are
Q nope sorry t no it says s yeah and
we're back
give me another one that's like that's
like when you smash the piano and strung
three notes together and now you're like
you got three right good I got three in
a row you
what's up
uh
Elemento
[__]
now I know
[Laughter]
we're dumb but you can't I mean that's
the same thing you learn it in a song
and that's the same thing where it's
like if I could do the numbers
seven eight no it's good
man how
apologize to the listening audience this
guy's got it
give me another one 14 15.
this kid ah nah you should be doing a
book get this get a checkbook will you
oh God
r
but that's it that the problem is that's
the start of a verse yep QRS so I just
have to I'm right there give me
something in the middle yeah [__] that
Eminem
h i
yeah yeah that's another one a b c d e f
g h i j k l m n o p
I don't know who came up with that
Johnny alphabet I know we ain't getting
no royalties on that oh yeah we might
that might be like the Happy Birthday
song where you gotta bleep that out
somebody might have that T-Bone
get [__] sued by Chiles or something
like that
now you can say the ABCs Charles Bradley
really 1834 knows um get it [__]
any of the Bradley's still floating
around no it's got to be public domain
yeah but happy birthday ain't no it
didn't it went back just recently yeah I
thought that was all [__] somebody
really had happy birthday
and we we talked about this on the Pod
probably like two years ago I didn't
believe it either but that's why I like
Chili's sings a different version
because they could technically be sued
that was my findings I just didn't think
they were idiots
[__] Steve can't remember the Happy
Birthday song
Steve you just hold the cake okay uh
unless I was remember poorly which does
happen from time to time but I thought
that's the findings of the show
previously I didn't believe that at all
and I still don't it doesn't make any
[__] sense to me that was a uh that
was that was a humbling thing waiting
tables
well you got to get together and do the
birthday I always felt so bad I didn't
know who to look at I didn't know to
receive it if it was at my table first
of all we never my family never did that
you'd have to be
we'd have to be with someone else's
family or something for that to happen
no way Denise and or my dad were
bringing over when you were a kid
unwanted attention no way Jose trying to
sneak out on this building
no way were they doing that Ryan family
everybody gets abuse the bathroom in the
checkups you don't like people looking
at us
one goes this way one goes that way all
I hear is the fire alarm go off can't be
hit it
uh car peeling out there five people
whistling different songs
[Laughter]
that was not for us I wouldn't do it Nat
would you do it now nah they tried to do
it uh at my birthday this year we went
out to dinner I was like please stop I
was like a [__] and it was a couple
whipped cream too
but you get a puppuccino at Starbucks a
cup of whipped cream they didn't want to
eat desserts that was just for show and
that was a slice of cheesecake or
something oh I wouldn't let him do it
yeah you're a real fatty mcaddy when
they bring out fake cake for you he
can't be trusted around a real stuff
just give them
give them some mayo and cold today
they got a candle in a cup of coffee
oh yeah
it was a little ramek and a whipped
cream they get the [__] out of here then
the kids got ice cream screaming at
everybody the [__] is it
it's my goddamn birthday but I wish
wouldn't come true if you can't fake it
can't fake things like you do believe in
wishes don't you yeah and you gotta have
the bite of something for the wish to
come true
your neighbors
hey buddy it's my birthday I want my
wish to come true real quick
man I gotta get a flower it's not a
corner a corner flower gonna sip it out
Martini while you're at it too
uh yeah that might be combination
fattest stupidest thing I've ever heard
what that you have to have a bite of
cake for your wish to come true I think
you do I think that's that's I'm not
saying you're that's probably a theory I
have never heard it I'm not I can't say
the wish that's yeah that's no you can't
say the wish and you gotta have a bite
of the thing it's like when you cheers
glasses and then you touch the thing you
have to take a sip otherwise it's bad
luck
I gotta make the rules yeah but luck and
wishes are different if we're splitting
here if we're if we're walking through
foleyville man if you're crazy enough
you're probably right and some I'm sure
some culture or somebody some lineage
does it for sure what's the rule on the
wish
you can't wish for more genies
I want four more birthdays you know this
might shock you but the research on
wishes is surprisingly
that's what Oppenheimer should have been
working on
be a lot better place
[Laughter]
he's working on wishes uh
creep
you are really something else oh Harvard
law says without a fight yeah who did
you think you were gonna fight myself
included what are the boys of Skunk
Works thing huh
let's get a think tank going on uh if if
the big man has to eat his cake after a
wish a couple MIT guys working on this
oh you're just watching videos of people
getting their face smashed into Kings
going know their wish what do you think
about that by the way someone smashed a
cake in my face when I when we were kids
that would have been a [__] brawl
first of all you just ruined the good
cake and Patty would have been pissed I
see once a mom's doing it to like
nine-year-old kids yeah they go in the
blood to candle and they they [__]
they curb stomp you and it will [__]
sheet cake
okay at least give me a fair one will
you [__] let's [__] shoot the fade
what are we talking about here that's
crazy
I think it would have been fun as a kid
in front of all your friends
it's man I mean in front of your friend
yeah but that's also like silly that's
not embarrassing it's not like if
somebody paints me that'd be different
I'd have to move [__]
go in the face now [__] that you would
have freaked out I would have if it was
hard yeah what do you mean if I was on
no it felt like if I stubbed my note
like
if I started crying in my cake because
you know sometimes you get hit in the
nose you're I start watering ice cream
cake fresh out the freezer
needs four stitches
ah you can't do that with a Carvel
are you kidding me that's like hitting
concrete oh have you ever had your nose
set in a cheddar cheese man
I still can't get over you that I'm
giving you a pup cup dude yeah [__]
something else sucked it's like a
strawberry in it
[__] out of here at that
I thought I told you this no
I remember telling you that they wanted
to sing Happy Birthday to me I guess I
admitted the pup cup
you and Han should be hanging out more
God likes the nice pups that was another
thing that's a great thing the pop cup
yeah they don't charge you I thought
they were gonna whack me for like 250 or
something a freebies out the door you're
a six-pack he'd be coming back
Hey listen he likes him when he gets to
that house do you wrap up you're eating
one
uh I can't be good for the dog though
what whipped cream sugar I think it's
fine fine I think that I mean I'm sure
I'll like you if you know he's doing
[__] five macchiatos a day yeah
little [__] get to him but I think a
pup Cup every now and then's all right
hit him with a frappuccino
uh
all right let's see here uh speaking of
very topical speaking of Kings Julian 10
Philly homie shout out to you is it
garbage to own any season of Cake Boss
on DVD
I've said it once I'll say it again say
it hit him I was over there in Jersey
City a couple years ago
Carlo's Bakery was over there in Jersey
loved the show when it was on I liked it
too and then it gets like all reality
shows they start off really good and
then they start jumping the cake a
little bit sure
um dark I had a you know I had my
I assumed it was good
I went over I think it was maybe I don't
know if it's the original one but it was
like a
it was it was when Jersey City which I
think where it started yeah I believe so
I had a cannoli over there
[__] blue my [__] hair back on but
for as big as that operation was don't
push out a good Canal a good good boots
on the ground dude it was it was
probably the best cannoli I ever had
and I've had a lot of them
I got on cannolis real young too young I
I just have beef with it you everything
you have that's decent is the best thing
you've ever had I'm telling you I mean
I'm telling you you probably say that
sentence 15 times a week give me
something else that I say to them you
just said yeah I literally about my pup
cup
I love a puppy you just did it down the
shore last week what I have it was like
it was something so it was like a french
fry like I gotta be honest with you I
don't know the turkey that I had from
Vegas Diner you had turkey from Vegas
Diner an open face turkey sandwich
where was I you guys were drinking that
sounds about right me and T-Bone were
home alone I have a real nice time a
real nice time yeah what'd you get
chicken Caesar wrap chicken Caesar wrap
best one I ever tasted oh it was so wet
it was just so wet with pickle juice it
was not good oh really it was terrible
oh they did an open face turkey sandwich
were real nice real turkey till it's I
couldn't believe that
I think it's probably been sitting there
since [__] night it was fresh it's
fresh probably a turkey it was probably
a turkey breast but it was real turkey
it wasn't lunch meat I mean yeah
it'd be tough if you said that was the
best turkey open face turkey sandwich
ever had it was sliced it was great but
that cannoli I'm telling you sure and I
got in the cannolis real young
a real young
Gem restaurant shout out to him I was
working back there I think I've probably
only ever had three cannolis in my life
that's crazy
one of the best desserts of all time you
like it cannoli love cannolis I love the
cannolis I love it
like I said I'm not a dessert guy but it
ain't there used to be a place in
Brooklyn I did a giant one they'd bring
it out like a cake you stick my favorite
birthday slam my face in that if you
want
it's like a party sub like a six foot
cannoli yeah yeah uh uh that's two times
uh all right let's do a couple uh two
three more here this one's from JB ever
seen anyone get into a public argument
while wearing flip-flops sure I've been
in public arguments wearing flip-flops
sure I think I've been in you know it's
like it's wearing flips you know it's
getting heated when someone takes them
off
hands are about to start being exchanged
which from a tactical standpoint
can't fight in flip-flops You're Gonna
Pop through them you're gonna rip
through it yeah but bare feet you're
loose yeah but you're cutting up unless
you're on hardwood floors if you're
outside Blood Sport you're not doing it
on broken glass you're on a side break
though if you're planting your feet
really trying to make a [__] power
move you ever stub your toe on the on
the on the sidewalk
that ain't Great Kills uh yeah no I've
for sure down to you know I for sure I
was a big flip I've slowly be coming
back to my flip-flop guy but I don't get
an old my [__] feet and my back have
killed me all week from [__] trudging
around and then [__] flip-flops I
can't wear them they make my ankles
swell up it's not good how do they make
your ankles swell up I don't know it's
something with the it cuts off
circulation in the thing I'm telling you
okay and I'm done with the Crocs except
for the prescriptions ones that I have
because they're rounded
I threw that pair out okay they cut me
fair enough yeah I'm out
the only guy I know can get hurt in the
most comfortable pair of shoes ever
created
so guys are walking around on clouds and
it's ah they cut me I probably had a
seashell in there or something
I have my blade in there
all right this is a take on one we've
talked about before different kind of
intake uh this one's from Ally is it
garbage to ask your arresting officer if
you can smoke a cigarette before he
takes you down to county jail is it even
more garbage if he says yes and hooks
one of your cuffs to a squad car door
handle so you can do so that's it that's
that's a good cop right that's a [__]
guy who gets it also
that's got to be lower level crime
maybe not I mean I think if you like
knock over a bank
they're getting you right in there no
fuss no you gotta prove not to be a
physical threat that's what you need
yeah of course catch a heater yeah also
what's real nice is when they're cuffed
we talked about Dog the Bounty Hunter
does it but when they light it for you
sure that lean back on a curve looks all
right dude all your cares in the world
melt away with that when your hands are
behind your back and go
that's not a comfortable one though it
don't matter it's needed at that moment
because you don't know when the next one
is if you've probably been on the run
you haven't had one in an hour your
[__] adrenaline's cooking you get
caught you need a stinger Boop Dogg's
always good to get with a heater take
care of your real dude sweet he knows
what it's like yeah I would extend that
courtesy as a cop myself even speeding
tickets what a hey I know this is
probably a stressful situation for you
what do you say we have a smoke
hahaha
you got one yours that's what I'm saying
yeah
smoking in the squad car we don't see
cops smoking anymore either Chase dudes
down that was more Cowboy [__] that was
more Sheriff the sheriff would smoke
he's out there you know when
in like movies and stuff oh yeah that's
what I'm saying like the 1800s no
there's not no there's not beat cops
like you don't see beat cops crank
probably back in the day probably not
allowed cops smoke on duty you
definitely can't smoke in a cop car
that's [__] government vehicle I'm
assuming
can't smoke on a bus whoa NYPD is
allowed to smoke weed
really yeah yes no [__] yeah they
stopped drug testing last year there was
a little bit there was a clip of a uh
very attractive female officer I thought
that was a that was fake hitting a blunt
smoking doobies
damn not on the job
[Laughter]
um yeah that's I was yes I would let if
I I think I would say I would let
everybody smoke and that's a solid move
if they're not a murderer or something
you know if you were in World War II
caught a soldier caught a couple of
Germans gentleman's move your Lieutenant
said listen they don't make it back take
him into the woods yeah show them what
it's like are you offering a heater I'm
a gentleman especially back then
everyone was cranking them but that's
where they make a move on you
Am I by myself no you got the
McCluskey with you I don't know well why
don't you mention that uh I mean it
depends are they cuffed they're not
coughed
are they no are they they got hands yeah
oh right we'll get to the tree line
those dudes are getting snipped and then
I'm having an eater deal with the souls
on my chest he doesn't pretend you're
looking for a lighter hey you guys know
hey
I wouldn't do that but I'm not I'm not
walking in the wooden with [__] yeah
and Kippy has radio operator written all
over him now I would be air strike Andy
oh I don't mind that I didn't have air
strikes World War II
would have figured him out
that's my job I got the checkbook
his favorite army guy was the guy on the
phone
I never got that guy what are you doing
we're on a pizza let's go
we're [__] taking heat over here
I was all flamethrower baby
the heat I loved the crawl but you're
making ribs yes got the Traeger out
doing creme brulee
on the front lines
that and the Bazooka guy was the best oh
yeah but he wasn't if you were set if
you were laying the land was he standing
or kneeling he was kneeling yeah that
guy that guy's not he's only good for
that you know what I mean he wasn't
really got one shot yeah I know that
guy's real [__] he's got to be you
know
I like the crawling guy because he can
move quick holding the gun on side yeah
he couldn't shoot he got some you get
the machine gun guy laying down that was
more like a sniper I feel maybe no it's
a machine gun because it had a little
stand
the more there was a mortar guy too
right uh-huh those guys were all right
yeah they were all they were always in
the back line yeah him and his homie
there was no snipers though it's a
little morbid
oh is the flame thrower and the Bazooka
you got the booby trap guy what got the
scalper
uh but we gotta wrap it up gang
this was a fun one this was a heat I
love yous both gang would love you to do
that stuff
I can't tell you I love you not cram
didn't like that when we were talking
about killing people
that makes it seem like you thought
about killing us and you decided not to
and told us you love you I give you a
smoke hey Kippy how do you say we go out
back and have a seat gang we love you to
death come see us in a road all over
baby we're adding shows shows are
selling out we're not Adam everywhere so
we don't snooze yeah because you're
gonna lose get your [__] Dickies and
let's [__] party gang to stay trashy
towards goddamn hoot love you to death
we'll see you next week